ask them this year say a lot of people
tell me shave your mustache say shall I
shave it or should I leave it like this
[Music]
so Angela
but I shadow fine
so high level things above
is it wait for me okay okay okay
Salaam alaikum WA Rahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends as you guys know we do reaction
videos on my channel but this reaction
video is a bit different insha'Allah and
you're gonna find out why where am i we
are in Lebanon in the border of Syria
and we have beautiful children around us
may Allah bless them orphans and we're
gonna bring you the same old
sobbing story even though the story is
very touching ah but we are going to
discuss it a bit but we're gonna put
smile on their faces each other I found
a video we're gonna react to some funny
cuts yeah okay what about Justine
Justine
I'm working on my jobs please okay
this guy's [ __ ] up of not there's
nothing on this video is a blank screen
mother no one said it wasn't one second
sorry and there's still lots of blank
it's a blank screen
wants it let's do this again ah one
second okay sorry one more time tell
them take two take two one more time you
ready Jesse
yes they love that empty screen so I'm
sure they're gonna be laughing at this
visit assalaam now
what's this what is Louis
janazah cat is bad now
music I'm now finish Bowen says it's
just that little reaction we do that we
just did Alison was it funny yeah okay
mashallah may Allah bless them inshallah
so what I'm gonna do is obviously when
we react it's not like your regular
YouTube is you know just react laugh ha
ha whoo and then that's it yeah this
definition Oh with no purpose behind it
inshallah so the purpose behind this
video is obviously to put smile in their
faces and we do not just want those
smiles to be on their faces just for
this one minute 30 seconds inshallah we
want those smiles on these kids faces
these children's faces for the next two
years and more inshallah so what we've
done is I've come here with human relief
foundation yeah and they're a charity
that I've been working with for the past
couple of years and hamdulillah like you
guys know I'm very specific I would like
to know what's going on extension so
I've come to the ground myself you're
going to see video footages of photo
shots where we are in a tent this is
where they are living we're going to
show you from the outside and from the
inside this is the conditions they're
living in and it's summer now so it's a
bit Karma it's a bit cooler but what
they go through winter I would not want
to imagine neither would I want to tell
you guys the descriptions but what do we
want for these kids and for other
households is well inshallah we want to
raise a certain amount that will sustain
this family because their story is very
very saddening yeah so we have by the
way before you guys know I always forget
this I forgot to introduce my guests
Salah oh sorry Salam Salam me a snack
organization Salam Marwa yeah sofa hello
suffer ok so far my wa salaam hello Wow
ok mashallah I forgot to introduce them
but you know maybe late
so Bhavan sisters I want you guys
inshallah to help us but before that
their story is very touching the father
passed away long time ago
the mother has left and gone got married
now a lot of people that Washington
like oh my gosh whatever mother etc we
do not know the conditions we do not
know their mental state yeah it's easy
for us to judge from the outside
appearance how could any mother do that
yes how could any mother do that but
then again what were the circumstances
why does she do that we do not know we
assume the best yeah but you can see the
beautiful children they do not have a
mother they do not have a father
yeah the least that we can do is help
them the Prophet peace be upon him said
that anyone that helps an orphan
yeah because someone misbehaving
mashallah may Allah bless him putting
smile on their faces yet the process
having said that you will be like this
in general yeah we all know that yeah
but knowing it getting happy about it is
not enough yeah yes what could you do
help these orphans they go school they
have they need clothes
the the aunty the auntie in my culture
they say auntie is like a mother and one
lightly I saw that why because she is
the one who's providing for them not
only for them but for her two sons yeah
and she was here crying why because she
has no choice but to go and work for the
rich I want to say in every single rich
person is Erica she's working for a rich
arrogant individuals who are cursing her
who who are making a life hard we do not
want her to go there what life is it
kind of fixture in mind we want her to
be sustained she can be with them like a
mother cheer them up inshallah help her
psychology she said her psychology was
affected this is what we want broken
sisters and you know how much roughly
roughly around estimations that we've
done is around
I think 350 to 500 pounds a month
roughly so rough estimate yeah every
single month will help to pay the rent
yes you heard that right this here they
pay a rent for yeah you know we when we
have houses we say our one on luxury
house with two bathrooms and I'll pay
this much they have to pay rent for this
place
yeah and they haven't eaten meat for one
whole month while la I feel ashamed we
have meat every single day for breakfast
we have breakfast meat for breakfast all
I'm saying is rather than sisters I'm
not here to convince you because they
don't need you you need this while llahi
by Allah you need this under their
judgement that sends the things that we
do one lie on the day of judgment we
need this and Allah spawn italics far
with our says in the Quran on that day
when your books are given to you when
your books are given to you yeah when
your books are given to you
and you'll okay and people are going to
say woe to us what kind of a book is
this that it has miss nothing small or
nothing big
do you know what that means that means
those times where you may be belittled
820 P or 10 P that you gave in charity
for this whatever it may be and you
thought nothing over he said I was just
MP gonna do for Allah that was bigger I
was a theme in your books is gonna be
written brothers and sisters I would run
in my books and everybody's books
inshallah on the bare judgment that you
help these orphans you put care to their
face you made them happy you help their
burden of the shorter of the ante not
only that they go school wherever they
do that they better that they do
anything the food that they eat you're
gonna be rewarded so I'm not gonna here
to I'm going to convince you
anyone that here's what I'm saying their
hands will go straight to their pocket
we need to get things rolling each other
that's about it and we just ask them is
there any message that when they give to
the people that are listening in there
is some anything maybe little message
whatever it maybe inshallah [ __ ]
awesome
no handsome one look that you look good
enough call and tell them if there's
nothing noise doesn't wondering well and
you know what lucky what she just said I
think she said I don't want to what I
don't know yes I would like people with
student knowledge they know a part of
knowledge is you say I don't know
yeah in my mind if they ask me so many
questions said I don't know that's a
pause notice funnel as you can see here
Marshall that's a beneficial mind anyone
any phenols any reminder that I wanna
give you see how are you
nothing asked them this year say a lot
of people tell me shave your mustache
say shall I save it or should I leave it
like this
this one but oh no but good no crease
good Selim whoever says good put the
thumbs up no quiz not good yeah good
I'll be keeping my mustache
if mooses watching this he's very
adamant for me to get rid of it but I
would not be brother and sisters that's
about it may Allah bless you guys
inshallah it was beautiful reacting to
that funny video with these kids and
seeing the smiles on their faces they
live a simple life and what lie they are
more happy than most of us we asked a
lot on trying to put that inner peace in
every single one of our heart and
especially those who would be donating
and those who cannot donate are sharing
this may Allah bless you guys too
- next time from assalamualaikum
warahmatullah better care to say Salaam
alaikum
[Music]